noren qualifié en direct avec bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
vous êtes étudiante en première année de
médecine cette réforme vous y être
confronté depuis plusieurs mois et vous
dénoncer une injustice expliquez nous
alors oui du coup bah je suis en
première année en passe donc s'appelle
passe maintenant c'est ce qu'avance
simple et a passé est ce donc on est
confronté à une nouvelle réforme
une rue une réforme qui n'est pas
préparée apparemment puisque ben moi je
suis à marseille et on et 1600 pour 193
places en médecine
vingt-et-une en dentaire 6 en maïeutique
je crois entre comme ça donc bon voilà
les chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes
c'est catastrophique c'est scandaleux
parce que quand je travaille de 8 heures
à 22 heures tous les jours depuis
septembre jusqu'à là j'ai passé mon
concours en le 19 20 21 avril et qu'on
te dit que ben peut-être que tu vas pas
passer parce que ben c'est la mauvaise
année et que l'année prochaine ils ont
plus de place que nous et les années
président 10 ans n'avait plus que nous
bon c'est vrai que c'est compliqué c'est
dur de se dire que dany la mauvaise
année en fait parce qu'on l'envoie de la
réforme de la première année de médecine
s'étaient pourtant de supprimer le
fameux numerus clausus le nombre de
places limité déterminée par l'état pour
qu'on comprenne mais en quoi est ce que
cette première année est
particulièrement compliqué pour vous
qu'est ce qu'elle change la réforme dans
le cursus de la première année en fait
un beau parcours
les années précédentes en passer tu
arrives et tu faisais ta première année
et si tout raté battu redoublé et en
général les gens ils passaient en 2e
année parce que ben il avait enfin leur
deuxième année en tant que double ans il
passait parce qu'ils avaient l'avantagé
aucunement qui connaissait pas le le
programme et c'est tout c'est que la
réforme elle part d'un bon d'un bon
sentiment dans le sens où elle voulait
supprimer cette injustice entre doublant
et primes ans le problème c'est que ben
il faut préparer cette forme et il ya
toujours une année de transition et le
problème c'est que ben l'année dernière
les primes en de l'année dernière belle
et double cette année
donc nous on arrive on a aussi notre
cursus en même temps et on doit se
partager nos places en vous
voilà c'est ça le problème cet avis est
partagé nos plateaux avec les doublants
de l'année dernière qui ont droit au
redoublement c'est leur droit
et nous qui expérimente en la peau la
réforme pour la première fois et qui du
coup avant moins de place des
informations on a eu que la la j'ai eu
mon demi russie à un mois un mois avant
le concours alors qu'on a des
spécialités à préparer donc je suis
désolé mais on a besoin de savoir où
nous placer par rapport à notre
classement pour savoir si bas ont peu
pris par les dentaires sont préparés
médecine etc des matières qui sont
différentes et on a eu le nombre de
places un moment avant le concours
lorsqu'elle a été présentée la réforme
lorsqu'elle a été présentée elle était
censée vous aider vous avez le sentiment
finalement que c'est l'effet inverse qui
se produit aujourd'hui bon clairement en
fait la nappe allait bien mais pour les
années d'après en fait nous avons subi
la transition elle a été clairement mal
préparée si elle n'avait pas laissé la
vie paris comme à paris ils ont eu un
numéro qui a été augmenté de 33 % 33
non nous on a eu un numéro qui était
augmenté de 6% à 12% pour les plus
chanceux et ça en fait c'est le nombre
de places qui bloque le manque
d'information lorsque moi
personnellement dans ma fac on a eu deux
nouvelles matières on savait pas comment
les préparer les professeurs n'ont pas
donné de qcm pour nous dire comment nous
préparer et c'est non c'est ça part
d'une bonne intention mais ça aurait pu
nettement en fait clairement si ça avait
été mieux préparé bon je pense que le
court il n'a pas raciste et anti justin
l'impact de cette crise sanitaire sur le
déroulé de vos études ben moi je vais
vous dire parce qu'après on a été on a
été confiné mais bon ils ont dit qu'ils
ont mis en place quelque chose bien et
le streaming
les profs étaient filmées ont regardé
les coffres après en direct etc
c'est la seule chose de bien et mise en
place du coup avoir surtout confinement
en octobre je prends novembre ont fait
plus aller à la fac jusqu'au concours et
après le deuxième semestre
non quelque chose c'est qu'on pouvait
aller par semaine il nous envoyer notre
convocation et on pouvait aller
au cours qui nous disant que faudrait-il
a amélioré l'année prochaine pour les
étudiants qui seront à votre place dès
le mois de septembre
qu'est-ce qu'il faudra améliorer ben
déjà je pense que c'est prévu le nombre
de places va augmenter ça c'est sûr
qu'il n'y aura pas de double en ben je
sais pas si dans les autres facs ce qui
a été mise en place dans ma fac a été
instaurée parce que je trouve que c'est
un peu différent si on me les facs donc
l'histoire du streaming c'est une très
très bonne idée
après midi passé avec la crise sanitaire
ça va changer les choses et ce qu'ils
pourront aller en présentiel etc
mais ça serait bien de retourner en
présentiel parce que ben des étudiants
en médecine à première année elle est
connue tu travailles toute la journée et
ben ça fait toujours une coupure de
pouvoir aller en cours et moi c'est ce
qui manquait en tout cas cette année
c'est que ben les cours de 8h à 12h pas
ça me permettait de voir autre chose que
mes cours et j'espère que au moins ils
auront la chance de pouvoir aller on en
fille et en présentiel et cetera
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
témoigner sur notre antenne noren
qualifier je rappelle que vous êtes donc
étudiante en première année de médecine
merci